see if you're a person he also gets us
off them as well so that's what's also a
nice thing is he kind of like you he's
got a little bit of the
your thing
you know your cheeky thing that thing
you do yeah i know i think so he's um
yeah look i always try and keep that i
think the cheekiness is something that
keeps you alive like father like son
prince harry is opening up about life
with his two little ones archie and
lillabet what's a wednesday like for you
it revolves around the kids as much as
humanly possible because whole working
from home stuff is
is is not all it's cracked up to be um
certainly post covered i mean lg spends
more time interrupting our zoom calls
um than anybody else um see if you're
personal he also gets us off them as
well so that's also a nice thing and i
can imagine that um he's probably one
very excited little two-year-old at the
moment and the novelty of a new baby in
the house is one that i think is going
to stay with the whole family for quite
a long time while speaking with today's
hoda kotb during his trip to the
netherlands for the 5th annual invictus
games the duke of sussex reveals what he
loves most about fatherhood all of it
the chaos
the learning
the reminder of
just every element of yourself your soul
right suddenly as a parent
especially now archie
he's out asking all the questions where
does he ask he just those questions of
the wife yeah he's into the y stage yeah
why this why that why that i love it i
love every every part of it i've always
wanted to be a dad i've always wanted to
have my own kids and i've got
two little people who i'm responsible
for prince harry also says that the
spirit of his late mother princess diana
who died in a car crash in 1997 is very
present in his kids lives do you tell
archie he's old enough about your mom
yes yeah yeah very much so i didn't
tell him all the stuff that happened but
suddenly that this is you know grandma
diana and got a couple of photos up in
the house and now the duke of sussex
says he feels her presence more than
ever it's almost as though she's
done her done her bit with my with my
brother and now she's very much like
helping me
got him set up now she's helping me set
up that's what it feels like you know i
feel her presence in almost everything
that i do now
um but definitely more so in the last
two years than ever before without
question
so
she's watching us another key woman in
his life his grandmother queen elizabeth
ii it was really nice to see her be able
to see her in some element of privacy
was was was nice before heading to the
netherlands harry and his wife meghan
markle stopped in the uk and visited the
queen for the first time in two years
well obviously it was hugely significant
harry and megan coming across the
atlantic the first time that they've
done this since 2020 harry very much has
wanted to see his grandmother who we
know has not been well he's wanted to
see her he's been in contact with the
queen she was just so nice to see her
you know she's on she's ungrateful and
always she's always got a great sense of
humor uh with me and i'm just making
sure that she's you know protected and
got the right people well you make her
laugh that's what she always says uh did
you do it again oh yes yeah i did both
make an eye tea with her so it was it
was really nice to catch up with her
your grandmother's gonna be 96 you know
what's the best thing about her she's
her sense of humor yeah and her ability
to see the the humor in so many so many
different things
we have a really special relationship we
talk about things that you can't talk
about with anybody else and while he
enjoyed his visit harry opens up about
his move across the pond away from the
royal family
home for me now is is you know for the
time being it's in this it's in the
states
and it really and it feels that way as
well
yeah it's we've been welcomed with open
arms um and it's got such a great
community up in santa barbara so
so you feel like that's home more for
you yeah is that weird to say
no but i'm sure it become a thing
at the top of harry's priority list he
wants his kids archie and lillabet to
spend time with their great grandmother
which begs the question will the
sussexes attend the queen's platinum
jubilee in june i don't know yet there's
lots of things with security
issues and everything else so this is
what i'm trying to do trying to make it
possible that you know i can get my kids
to meet she hasn't met her
great-granddaughter lilly bear she
hasn't seen archie for nearly two years
now and she hasn't seen harry for well
over a year so she will have been i can
imagine that she would be very pleased
to have seen harry and you know we'll
hope that this will be the first of many
visits back to the uk
[Music]